Today we will examine a leading case on the parol evidence rule Alaska northern
development versus Alyeska pipeline services.
Suppose you sign a written contract but at the time of signing you'd agreed to
additional terms orally are the additional oral law or agreement terms and
forcible the parole evidence rule determines when parties to a written contract
can present extrinsic evidence to clarify or add to terms in the written
contract.
The parole evidence rule is related to our earlier discussion of the statute of
frauds.
The statute of frauds determines when non four corners evidence.
Extrinsic evidence can establish the existence of a contract while the parole
evidence rule determines when non four corners evidence can establish the terms
of a contract.
Both rules can be seen as attempts at deterring parties from falsely alleging
that a duty is owed.
The statute of frauds makes it harder for someone to falsely claim that she had
an oral agreement with someone else.
The parole evidence rule,
it makes it harder for someone to falsely claim that an actual agreement
includes additional terms that were never agreed to,
but both rules can perversely increase the amount of fraud by making it easier
for someone to falsely deny the existence of actual promises.
Here the parole evidence rule can make it easier for someone who actually agreed
in an ancillary oral agreement to take on additional responsibilities to falsely
deny that she ever promised to do so.
The parole evidence rule is a substantive rule in contract cases.
The word parole literally means word and parole.
Evidence refers to evidence outside the four corners of the written agreement.
The parole evidence rule is a common law rule that is also codified in the UCC
section two Dash Two oh two broadly speaking,
the rule states that where the parties to a contract intended for their written
agreement to be the full and final expression of their bargain,
other written or oral agreements that were made prior to or a simultaneous with
the writing are inadmissible for the purpose of changing the terms of the
written agreement.
To take a clear example.
If Roger Agrees in writing to sell a widget to Julie for $2,000 Julie cannot
argue that Roger Orally told her she would only need to pay $1,000.
The parole evidence rule would prevent Julie from bringing evidence of the oral
agreement that contradicts the written agreement.
But it does allow,
uh,
the terms to be explained or supplemented unquote if the conditions of
subsection a and B are met.
There is a complicated,
this is a,
uh,
this section of the UCC is incredibly complicated and among other things,
it's important to keep in mind whether the extrinsic evidence is being offered
to explain an ambiguous term or whether it's being offered as a supplemental
term.
The UCC always has the potential to allow extrinsic evidence,
including course of dealing or usage of trade or course or performance evidence
to be offered to help interpret or explain an ambiguous term,
but it's sometimes precludes extrinsic evidence to supplement contracts.
The key reasons for excluding extrinsic evidence for the purpose of
supplementing is when the agreement is integrated.
The restatement.
Second of contracts defines integrated agreements as writings that constitute
quote,
a final expression of one or more terms of the agreement unquote.
There are two types of integrations and integrated agreement is either partially
or completely integrated.
Completely integrated agreement is a final expression of all of the terms as to
which the parties agreed or as the restatement puts it,
an agreement adopted quote by the parties as a complete an exclusive statement
of the terms of the agreement unquote.
Nowadays,
parties may choose to include a merger or integration clause,
which simply states that the written contract is a complete Lee integrated one.
The name merger clause is a bit misleading.
It might suggest that any ancillary oral agreements are merged into and become
part of the written agreement,
but it means just the opposite that any ancillary oral agreements are not merged
into the,
uh,
into the enforceable part of the written agreement.
A partially integrated agreement is just any integrated agreement.
That's not the complete and exclusive statement of all the agreed terms.
It contains some,
but not all of the final terms of the,
uh,
that the parties have agreed to.
The difference between a complete and partially integrated contract is an
important part of the controversy in the Alyeska.
A case
plaintiff appellant buyer,
uh,
Alaska northern development a and d submitted a letter of intent to the
defendant appellee seller Alyeska proposing to purchase defendants inventory of
Caterpillar machinery parts.
Defendant responded with this similar letter condition condition,
though upon quote,
final approval of the owner committee unquote.
Neither letter specified the price for the proposed sale at a subsequent meeting
between representatives of the two firms,
the price was agreed upon and added to the defendant's letter.
Defendant's representative Ricketts Alyeska is manager of contracts and material
management signed this modified letter.
Uh,
the defendant's owner's committee,
however,
refuse to sell on any grounds,
not just because they disagreed on price.
The trial court granted summary Judgment for the defendant and the instant court
affirmed.
Before we move on to the holdings in this case,
let's make sure we understand the facts.
What type of parole evidence does uh,
and,
and the buyer in this case want to introduce?
Well,
Andy wants to introduce extrinsic evidence that the parties agreed that final
approval that this final approval clause was meant to limit owner the owner's
committee to consideration of whether the price was fair and reasonable and that
and that was the only basis on which they could turn down the uh,
contract.
If the owner committee rejects the contract for other reasons,
it would be a breach in other word and wants to introduce extrinsic evidence to
argue that Alyeska his conduct was a breach of the contract.
The issue in this case is whether plaintiff's parole evidence this extrinsic
evidence was correctly excluded at top.
At trial,
the court held that yes,
the exclusion of parole evidence was proper.
There was a partial integration of the writing and given this,
the alleged oral agreement to limit approval to price is not a consistent
additional term because it was not in reasonable harmony with the integrated
writing before we take on the courts multistep tests to determine whether the
extrinsic evidence can be used to supplement the agreement.
Let's look at how the court responded to the plaintiff's argument that the
extrinsic evidence should be admitted to explain.
And a,
and then big ewas term courts will only allow extrinsic evidence to be
introduced to explain a written provision.
If that written provision is ambiguous and the extrinsic evidence is offered in
support of an interpretation to which the writing is reasonably reasonably
susceptible.
Reasonable susceptibility is the crucial concept in this diagram.
Each point inside the blue oval represents a different possible interpretation
to which the writing is reasonably susceptible.
Courts apply section t applying section two,
two oh two would admit extrinsic evidence to help support and interpretation
inside the oval,
but not an interpretation that lies outside the set of interpretations to which
the writing is reasonably susceptible.
So the court would allow admitting explit extrinsic evidence to support an
interpretation.
Let's say here,
but not to support an interpretation.
Let's say out here.
So for example,
imagine a written contract with a covenant not to compete,
which has a smudged duration number,
which might have originally been written as either a to as either two or three
years.
Uh,
a court would not allow extrinsic evidence to explain to,
uh,
to explain this ambiguity if,
if the evidence was it was to be admitted to suggest that the parties had agreed
to a four year duration because the writing is,
is ambiguous,
but does not reasonably susceptible to that four year interpretation.
Yeah.
The Alyeska court similarly found that the December 11th letter was not
reasonably susceptible to the interpretation advanced by a and D,
and that therefore there was no merit to a and ds contention that it was
entitled to a jury trial on this interpretation issue.
In the next video,
we'll take on the difficult multipart test governing whether extrinsic evidence
should be admitted to supplement the agreement.